well folks we're coming to the end of
2020
a year in which the government was
forced to tell people how to live their
lives
how long to wash their hands how many
households
could meet together and the year in
which we lost
too many loved ones before their time
and
so i can imagine that there will be
plenty of people who will be only
too happy to say goodbye to the grimness
of 2020. but just before we do i want to
remind you
that this was also the year when we
rediscovered a spirit
of togetherness of community it was a
year in which we banged saucepans to
celebrate the courage and self-sacrifice
of our nhs staff and care home workers
a year in which working people pull the
stops out
to keep the country moving in the
biggest crisis we've faced
for generations shop workers transport
staff
pharmacists emergency services everyone
you name it
we saw a renewed spirit of volunteering
people delivered food to the elderly and
the vulnerable
and time after time as it became
necessary to fight
new waves of the virus we saw people
unite in their determination
our determination to protect the nhs and
to save lives
putting their lives your lives on hold
buying precious time for medicine to
provide
the answers and it has in 2020 we've
seen
british scientists not only produce the
world's first effective treatment
of the disease but just in the last few
days
a beacon of hope has been lit in the
laboratories
of oxford a new room temperature vaccine
that can be produced cheaply and at
scale
and that offers literally a new
lease of life to people in this country
and around the world and with every jab
that goes into the arm
of every elderly or vulnerable person
we're changing the odds
in favor of humanity and against covid
and we know that we have a hard struggle
ahead of us for
weeks and months because we face a new
variant of the disease
that requires a new vigilance
but as the sun rises tomorrow on 2021
we have the certainty of those vaccines
pioneered in a uk that is also free
to do things differently and if
necessary better
than our friends in the eu free to do
trade deals around the world and free
to turbo charge our ambition to be a
science
superpower from biosciences to
artificial
intelligence and with our world-leading
battery and
wind technology we will work with
partners
around the world not just to tackle
climate change
but to create the millions of
high-skilled jobs
this country will need not just this
year 2021
as we bounce back from covid but in the
years
to come this is an amazing moment
for this country we have our freedom
in our hands and it is up to us
to make the most of it and i think it
will be the overwhelming instinct of the
people of this country to come together
as one
united kingdom england scotland wales
and northern ireland working together to
express our values
around the world leading both the g7 and
the cop
26 climate change summit in glasgow
an open generous outward-looking
internationalist
free trading global britain that
campaigns for 12 years of quality
education
for every girl in the world
2021 is the year we can do it
and i believe 2021 is above all
the year when we will eventually do
those everyday things
that now seem lost in the past bathed in
a
rosy glow of nostalgia going to the pub
concerts theatres restaurants or simply
holding hands
with our loved ones in the normal way
we're still a way off from that there
are tough
weeks and months ahead but we can see
that
illuminated sign that marks the end of
the journey
and even more important we can see with
growing clarity exactly how we're going
to get there
and that is what gives me such
confidence
about 2021 happy new year